una nueva forma de celebrar una
tradición estadounidense a pesar de las
advertencias de no viajar miles de
personas en la unión americana planean
hacerlo para la víspera del día de
acción de gracias este jueves
casi que me da pena que me vean viajando
en televisión cuanto aconsejaron no
hacerlo pero estoy aquí por un tiempo
corto mi hijo ha estado aquí durante
siete años lo extraño y realmente quiero
verla
y es que el número de contagios va en
aumento dimensionar las más de 250.000
muertes causadas por el patógeno que
parecen no ser impedimento para los
viajeros
yo estaba un poco preocupado de ver
algunos familiares que tienen riesgos de
salud secundarios tome todas las
precauciones y por supuesto utilizar una
máscara porque es necesario las
autoridades estiman que mínimo 5
millones de personas empezaron a viajar
desde inicios de esta semana algunos
estados como alaska requieren de pruebas
negativas para garantizar la entrada es
por eso que miles están en una carrera
contrarreloj para realizarse pruebas
tengo muchos familiares que amo y que me
importan aquí en esta zona y para que yo
pueda celebrar el día de acción de
gracias con ellos sentí que era
importante tener alta precaución y
realizarme una prueba con aglomeraciones
inevitables que resultarían en más casos
positivos algunos estadounidenses
planean celebrar la cena del tradicional
pavo acomode el lugar este año las
autoridades ni siquiera prevé en un
pronóstico de vuelos por la volatilidad
de la crisis sanitaria